ahora que ya sabemos cómo se puede
propagar una señal a través de una
neurona a través de potenciales electro
tónicos y potenciales de acción y
combinaciones de ambos
pongámoslo todo junto mirando nuevamente
la estructura de la neurona la anatomía
de la neurona y pensar en por qué tiene
esa anatomía y cómo puede funcionar todo
ya hemos mencionado que las dendritas
son donde la neurona puede ser
estimulada por múltiples señales de
entrada si estuviéramos en el cerebro
estas dendritas podrían estar cerca de
los finales de las terminales de los
axones de otra neurona si fuéramos algún
tipo de célula sensorial estas dendritas
podrían ser estimuladas por algún tipo
de señal de entrada sensorial
pero digamos sólo como hipótesis que son
estimuladas de alguna manera y ya que
son estimuladas de alguna manera
permite que iones positivos fluyan al
interior de la neurona desde el exterior
como sabemos hay una diferencia de
potencial es más negativo el interior de
la neurona que el exterior y entonces si
un canal se abre debido a un estímulo
eso permitirá que iones positivos fluyan
al interior
los iones positivos primarios de los que
hemos hablado son los iones de sodio
quizá esta es algún tipo de puerta de
sodio que se abre debido al estímulo
cuando eso sucede
tendrás propagación electro tónica
tendrás potencial electro tónico
propagándose digamos que tenemos un
voltímetro justo aquí en la loma de la
acción es como una loma que guía a la
acción de aquí lo que deberías de ver
después de un periodo de tiempo es
déjame dibujar
digamos que esto es mi voltaje en mil
volts a través de la membrana debería de
decir una diferencia de voltaje esto
representa el paso del tiempo digamos
que el estímulo ocurre en el tiempo cero
justo en el tiempo cero no lo hemos ni
siquiera detectado con nuestro
voltímetro aquí nuestro voltaje allí a
través de la membrana está en equilibrio
con menos 70.000 volts pero después de
algo de tiempo este potencial electro
tónico ha llegado a este punto porque
todas estas cargas positivas se están
intentando alejarse unas de otras y
podrías ver una cresta en el voltaje en
la diferencia de voltaje podría decir
esto podría ir hacia arriba debería de
verse parecido a esto eso por si mismo
podríamos decir que no obtenemos una
diferencia de voltaje en lo
suficientemente baja o podríamos no
haber
el voltaje dentro de la membrana adentro
de la célula lo suficientemente positivo
para poder activar los canales de iones
regulados por voltaje y entonces ya no
pase nada quizá esto de aquí es menos
55.000 volts y entonces eso es lo que
tienes que obtener el voltaje límite la
diferencia de voltaje el límite para
poder activar los canales de iones que
están ahí los canales de sodio dejan que
fluya carga positiva al interior aquí
están los canales de potasio que
permiten a las cargas positivas fluir al
exterior
la loma de la acción tiene muchas de
estas porque cuando son activadas pueden
activar un impulso y después puede ir a
través de todo el axón y quizá estimular
otras cosas tal vez en el cerebro o en
cualquier otro lugar donde puede estar
conectada a esta neurona quizá ésta se
estimula por sí misma y lo activa pero
digamos que hay otro estímulo que sucede
exactamente al mismo tiempo alrededor
del mismo tiempo eso pasa y por sí misma
eso podría causar un tipo similar de
cresta por aquí o cuando sumas a las dos
si ocurren al mismo tiempo son crestas
que se combinan sus crestas combinadas
son suficientes para activar los
potenciales de acción de la loma o
series de potenciales de acción en la
loma y entonces realmente has activado
la neurona y entonces ahora todo tipo de
cargas positivas
fluyen hacia el interior de la neurona
y entonces únicamente a través de
propagación electro tónica tendrás este
potencial electro tónico propagado a lo
largo del axón esta es la parte
interesante porque puedes pensar un poco
acerca de cuál es la mejor manera en la
que una acción puede ser diseñado
generalmente si estás intentando
transferir una corriente lo mejor que
puedes hacer es que lo que transferirá
la corriente
conduzca muy bien o podrías decir que
tenga una
si a baja resistencia pero quieres que
esté rodeado por un aislante esta de
aquí es una sección transversal quieres
que esté rodeado por un aislante que
tenga una alta
y la razón es porque no quieres que el
potencial fluya a través de tu membrana
necesitas una red
ya
alta aquí si no tuvieras una alta
resistencia alrededor de él entonces tu
señal de hecho se transferiría tu
corriente de hecho iría más despacio
todo esto tiene que ver con la
electrónica si solo tienes un montón de
alambres de cobre en un lado y tienes
algunos alambres de cobre que estaban
rodeados por un excelente aislante con
una resistencia muy buena por ejemplo
plástico o algún tipo de caucho la
corriente de hecho tendrá menos pérdida
de energía por lo que viajará más rápido
cuando está rodeada por un aislante y
podrías decir de acuerdo lo mejor que
podríamos hacer es rodear este acción
entero con un buen aislante y en la
mayor parte de eso es cierto está
rodeado por un buen aislante eso es lo
que la vaina de mielina
digamos que queremos rodear todo esto
con un solo grupo de células de schwann
con una sola vaina de mielina grande que
es un buen aislante no conduce bien la
corriente esto de aquí es una gran vaina
no una vaina y cuál es el problema con
esto si este acción es muy largo si
fueras un dinosaurio y este acción
intentará ir a lo largo de todo tu
cuello y tu cuello es de 25 pies de
largo o incluso un ser humano de una
altura razonable tendrá que tener una
longitud de varios pies o quieres ir a
través de una distancia razonable
únicamente con la propagación electro
tónica recuerda que tu señal se disipa
tu señal será muy débil justo aquí
tendrás una señal
de bill
en el otro lado podría incluso no ser lo
suficientemente fuerte para hacer que
algo interesante suceda estas terminales
no serían lo suficientemente fuertes
para incluso activar otras neuronas o
hacer que otra cosa suceda en este otro
extremo así que déjame decir de acuerdo
bien porque no intentamos estimular la
señal bueno de qué manera estimular una
señal podrías decir
ok me gusta tener esta vaina de mielina
pero porque no ponemos huecos en la
vaina de mielina de vez en cuando y
porque no esos huecos le permiten a la
membrana tener una interfaz con el
exterior y en esas áreas podemos poner
algunos canales regulados por voltaje
que puedan activar potenciales realmente
cuando se quiera esencialmente estimular
la señal así es exactamente la anatomía
típica de las neuronas en lugar de sólo
una gran vaina de mielina aquí será
déjame hacer unos huecos aquí déjame
solo borrar esto
esto con eso basta y entonces lo que
podemos hacer es podemos hacer huecos
justo aquí donde el axón donde la
membrana por sí sola pueda tener una
interfaz con sus alrededores y por
supuesto sabemos que llamamos a esos
espacios los nodos de ram bien déjame
poner esos nodos aquí ponemos a esos
espacios aquí en la vaina de mielina y
este de aquí es un no
run
estos son los nodos de ramier y justo en
esos pequeños nodos donde no hay vaina
de mielina puedo poner estos canales
regulados por voltaje para esencialmente
estimular la señal si la señal debe de
ir de manera electrónica por todo el
largo de la acción sería muy débil se
disipará mientras avanza a través de la
acción pero podría ser lo
suficientemente fuerte en este punto
para poder activar estos canales
regulados por voltaje para poder
esencialmente estimular la señal otra
vez para poder activar los potenciales
de acción para poder estimular la señal
y después de que la señal es estimulada
se disipará y se disipará será
estimulada justo aquí otra vez y luego
se disipará se disipará y se disipará y
luego se estimulará continuará
disipándose y volverá a estimular se y
entonces al tener esta combinación
a la vaina de mielina quieres un
aislante para poder mantener la
transmisión de la corriente rápidamente
para perder la menor cantidad de energía
pero si necesitas estas áreas donde no
hay vaina de mielina para poder
estimular la señal para que los
potenciales de acción sean activados y
que la señal sigue siendo amplificada si
quieres hablar de eso pregunta a un
ingeniero eléctrico acerca de este tipo
de conducción donde la señal solo sigue
siendo estimulada
y si bien es esto superficialmente
pareciera como si las señales estuviera
solo saltando se estimula aquí y luego
se estimula aquí se estimula acá luego
acá y luego acá a esto se le llama
conducción salta toria
duch
acción
sal
uría
y viene de la palabra en latín saltaré
que significa brincar alrededor saltar
alrededor y eso es porque se ve como si
las señales estuviera saltando alrededor
pero eso no es exactamente lo que está
pasando la señal está viajando
pasivamente a través se activa aquí en
la loma de la acción luego viaja
pasivamente a través de propagación
electro tónica y luego es estimulada
tiene la vaina de mielina alrededor para
asegurar de que vaya lo más rápido
posible porque tienes una pérdida de
señal muy pequeña y luego es estimulada
en los nodos de ramier porque activa
estos canales regulados por voltaje otra
vez los cuales activan el potencial de
acción y luego la señal se estimula se
disipa se estimula se disipa se estimula
se disipa se estimula se disipa
se estimula nuevamente y luego puede
activar cualquier otra cosa que necesite
activar